I'm a you you had some oo and a people
are excited about this book I'm just
saying I'm just saying good go get it I
know exactly how are the holidays going
for you they're going great and uh yeah
I like this time of year and me too and
uh I know you you like the spirit I love
it um but I hear this about you too you
played football right as far as I know
yes you did you definitely did I Googled
it because I recently got into football
I like hardcore crazy like I'm look at
you I love
it are do you did you love it did you
love playing yeah yeah do you watch do
you watch religiously like I watch uh I
don't have like a team I follow really
really yeah but I but I have players I
follow oh I like that yeah like maybe
you meet someone or maybe someone's a
guest on your show and all of a sudden
you go yeah hey Troy Aman right yeah
well I'm Texan so Cowboys yeah that's
why I said
nicely done nicely done yeah I was like
I've been following him for but if you
meet Troy Aman and I meet him CU he's a
UCLA guy and so am I yeah but every once
a while they have a quarterback me you
know like a like a gathering right yeah
so you go and I don't go to a lot of
them but when you go and Troy is there
yeah Troy's a Monster yeah I mean Troy
Troy is like six six and like and really
good at football really good at football
and big legs and big body and hands that
could Encompass your whole head right
and uh so when I played we were a bunch
of little option triple option guys you
like six feet guys yeah that would run
around and do a whole different offense
yeah oh my gosh do you get into fantasy
at all fantasy
football you I'm glad you said fantasy
football that was like the whole
thing both are acceptable I got it both
are acceptable both are fun um no I you
do it but no because you like players
that's what I'm saying like I like
players but I don't like them like that
yeah I know but you know what it opened
my eyes to other players said open my
that now I follow them and I get mad at
them but I get I follow them more so
than just my team it's kind of have you
ever met any of them yes I hosted the
NFL honor so I met yeah so sometimes
it's cool sometimes not so cool well I
think Dak was probably like man can you
lay off me cuz he's a Cowboy player and
I I gave my team more crap than anyone I
get it because you have to and also I
want to go to the Super Bowl so it's
like I bet you could do that you know
yeah I can't but my team he's been doing
he did really well this past I'm just
saying you could maybe get into fantasy
football it's really fun no okay he said
hard no I'll do another team for you
another league and also call it Mark
harman's I heard that you took at UCLA
you took a jazz class like about jazz
like the history of you know you know
sometimes jazz is hard for me well yeah
at the time it was called history of
jazz yeah and I was I was a football
player so that that was thought of as a
mick okay a mi Mickey Mouse class right
um wait what okay no it's like a Class A
class with 600 people in it they don't
take uh attendance so you can oh a bird
course you fly right there same kind of
thing oh bird course okay Bird Okay an
now I'm going to use yours okay okay
yeah and and and anyway I found myself
in that class okay but this guy's name
was Paul Tanner and he was a jazz M
musician and he played in the Dixie Land
quartet at Disneyland every summer oh
wow but he's one of those guys for me
just for me in in my college experience
that's a special one and I and I got a
chance to to tell him that before he
passed and and he was a he was a gift I
mean I've never forgotten him and and
you have certain teachers that move you
that open well he moved me but but but I
wasn't supposed to be in there in the
first place right so it it was a mick
yeah yeah bird thing bird course yeah
fly right through it um I'm gonna use
Mickey Mouse though now yeah seems a
little more fun I don't know how you get
there with Mickey Mouse but I'm going to
ask in the commercial break so a couple
of your older projects have gotten new
life I don't know if you know this but
we hear that there's a potential Freaky
Friday Sequel and summer school is
blowing up online like did you expect
that 35 years later that is it's all
blowing up like people are wanting the
sequel and now they're talking about
this again well uh the the the first one
is because Jamie's talking about it yeah
and you know Jamie yeah I love Jamie I
do too and I've known her since she was
15 so oh wow if she if she's talking
about it then it'll happen it's probably
going to happen because all things
happen yes very but it's did you ever
expect the other one though summer like
for 35 years later yeah SU school no
yeah no uh I was just so thrilled that
Carl Riner was interested in me to play
this part and and then my wife read the
script at the same time so don't Don't
Go Near this don't don't do this but we
have very different opinions of material
and things like that which is healthy
but uh I just said he thinks I can do
this yeah so I'm G to do it yeah I went
and did it I love that and all those
kids but I love that it's like blowing
back up I just think it's cool when it
comes back around it's like music people
like Mike I hear young kid talk about
that's like from the 70s like what yeah
and and all those people were young and
just starting out at that time right so
so those kids were all over 30 when they
were playing high school kids so of
course every one of them had an idea
after every SC hey Carl hey Carl hey
Carl can I do this and he'd go no no
stick to it yeah and but so many of the
little threads at the end of every scene
that he let the camera roll on are in
that film oh cool and I had a chance to
work with him later years laying down a
track for the for the the movie years
later yeah U and a chance to sit with
him for four hours and and do that and I
I love that opportunity to finally tell
him what he meant to me oh that's so
cool yep yeah you like to tell people
that I like that about you so far in
this and you like to like let people
know that theyve like made a change and
an impact in your life that's cool I was
telling you that on the way out I well
nobody not everybody does that yeah why
I don't know I don't know maybe they
feel foolish or whatever all time I do
I'm like well I'm a very chatty person
in general so I tell everybody
everything that's there's a there's a
there's a kindness in that it's not just
being a chatty person yeah it makes me
feel good to tell someone that they've
made a big impact on me yeah yeah yep um
what about like NCIS like this show is
in ingrained in us it was in my
household for so long like mine too I I
know like that's I know but like just
saying goodbye to that like it's been a
couple years right now so like what do
you what do you feel like now do you
miss it I I I think for the longest time
I was just tired it's long hours oh yeah
yeah yeah originally part of it taking
the job being home for a young family
not traveling as much doing movies and
whatever yeah um the first day we worked
22 hours so I thought that's not exactly
what I thought this was going to be uh
but there we had a lot of days like that
in the first four years so um that it's
been the success it's become that's
great to be part of that is great you
know writers change Runners change casts
change all that uh and I always tried to
pay attention to that and daily uh tried
to do what my title said which is you
know read ahead and note ahead and do
all those kind of things yeah uh and
it's a lot you know um and and I again I
paid attention to the writing room yeah
which is important and then and that
that that was successful I'm proud of
and the people who are part of that it's
how I met Leon Carroll who end up right
book with and uh and I wouldn't trade
that relationship with with anyone so um
I'm proud of it in a different way I
love that this relationship carried over
with Leon as well because he you you
ended up co-authoring this book and it's
and he you worked with him on NCIS did
he's a real agent right yeah and in the
beginning Kelly when when I I tried to
look up in CIS I'd never heard of it
they said I'd never heard of it before
your show okay you you know about it
because of the show yes but it had been
around for a long time long long time
okay and and the reason you didn't know
about it is because these people doing
this work it's really difficult work and
and they do their job better if no one
knows about it that's that's really why
okay so then there's a TV show and I'm
trying to figure out how to play a
character so I'm trying to ask questions
of someone who knows even what it is
right and I meet Leon Carroll and he's
my guy I mean he's the real deal he's
he's he's a real special agent okay I'm
an actor yeah big difference big
difference but I over the years there
was never an interrogation uh on that
show that I ever did without talking to
him first and and asking him about how
he would do it what's the right way to
do that you know how to put on a pair of
handcuffs how to whatever it was there
there were a thousand things I had to
day with him but in over 20 years over
19 years we developed a bond and and
this show was originally based on real
cases originally and then things changed
like I said um and so when this book
opportunity happened it was like if we
could tell real stories of the agency
and the first story is is this book
ghost and and it's you know a com
combined authorship of the two of us
that that we just thought there was a
story worth telling and the people
you're asking and talking to about this
they've never been asked to talk about
it before yall should start a podcast
too is all I'm saying this is a well
Mark's co-author Leon Carroll is in our
audience right now so I need to ask
though was Mark was he a good student
like he's up here being like I had to
learn how to hold the handcuffs I had to
learn how how was he really Mark was the
best student around oh wow he wanted to
know all the intricate things about law
enforcement and it was great but the
most important thing on set he was a
prankster every night I'd come home with
the cookies that I had taken from the
craft service table reach into my pocket
and now I bring up Rusty bolts and
nails so you knew you were love that day
a I love that wait so describe the new
book for
everyone uh it's ghost of Honolulu ghost
of Honolulu it's really about the the
the birth of the
agency back Pearl Harbor yeah and uh a
special agent named Doug wat Douglas W
and it's really his story and really the
story and birth of the agency so so it's
something we're proud of we worked
really hard on it and uh I'm proud of my
partner oh man that's so cool I love y
like doing this cuz it's creative but
it's also informative which is my
favorite kind of learning um we need
another break though um but Mark's book
is called ghost of Honolulu it's out now
W Mark and Leon's books um everyone in
our audience is getting a copy
yeah she just won a
car
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home